Salut ! Une énigme par jour pendant 32 jours, à l'intérieur du défi du Mental Vlog.
Je vais commencer à vous donner la solution de l'énigme d'hier.
Si vous n'avez pas vu l'énigme d'hier,  foncez la voir de suite parce que là je vais donner la réponse tout de suite, donc ce serait dommage de ne pas avoir vu l'énigme avant.
Comment, en rajoutant un seul trait, on peut transformer ce 9, écrit en chiffres romains, en un 6 ?
En un seul trait. On a dit en un seul trait, donc sans lever le stylo, en un seul trait mon 9 devient un 6.
Non ce n'est pas une arnaque !
C'est une solution, tout à fait acceptée et acceptable.
Et je pense que beaucoup d'entre vous l'ont trouvé.
Je verrai ça dans les pouces en l'air de la vidéo d'hier.
Et si jamais vous ne l'aviez pas trouvé, vous allez sûrement trouver celle d'aujourd'hui.
L'énigme de cette vidéo 14 est somme toute un peu plus simple que d'habitude.
C'est surtout un grand classique dans les énigmes.
Peut-être, il y en a certains qui vont la connaitre.
Mais c'est important de la mettre pour ceux qui ne la connaisse pas.
Vous avez 9 cases, que vous pouvez vous aussi dessiner sur un papier.
Vous devez placer 10 vaches dans ces 9 cases.
Vous vous débrouiller comme vous voulez, il ne peut y avoir, qu'un seul élément par case.
Vous devez rentrer 10 vaches dans ces 9 cases.
La réponse, vous l'aurez demain à 17H dans le prochain Mental Vlog.
Si vous vous avez la bonne réponse, ou si vous connaissiez l'énigme, ne le mettez pas dans les commentaires,
mettez simplement un pouce en l'air.
Ce qui permettra de voir le pourcentage de personnes qui ont trouvé la solution, ou qui connaissaient déjà l'énigme
quand on comparera le nombre de pouces en l'air par rapport au nombre de vues.
Passez...
un bel été !
Pensez à vous abonner avant de partir, et rendez-vous demain.
Ciao !